hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV
we're in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest and
we're talking now with the great
governor gary johnson two-term elected
republican governor of New Mexico
running for the Republican nomination
Gary thanks for sitting with us Nick
great seeing you what you've been out on
the hustings here for a while what are
your issues that are gaining the most
traction for people well you know I
don't want to say I'm gaining traction
in any way I mean I'm out there talking
about these issues constantly and the
issues as I see them are the fact that
we're bankrupt we are bankrupt and
unless we fix this I just think we're
going to find our sell all of us are
going to find ourselves with nothing
we're going to find ourselves in two
decades of strike what's the quick fix
or is there a quick fix on on being
bankrupt what areas is your federal
guarantee it there is a quick fix
there's a quick fix and I don't think
it's so unpalatable I don't think it's
so unreasonable to think that we
couldn't actually balance the budget do
that hey we're safe do you balance that
through tax increases no you don't you
don't you don't no no tax increases
whatsoever I've become an advocate of
the Fair Tax which by all my free
economist what is the perfect fairtex
would be the consumption text one-one
federal tax so you're going to do away
with the income tax you're going to do
away with the IRS all federal taxes with
the exception of one federal tax also
does away with corporate tax does away
with business-to-business tap is this
and what fair tax or argue that's the
okay what what's the amount of revenue
you're expecting to raise it is the
Senators GDP well then it's a revenue
neutral so in this case revenue neutral
so it still necessitates a forty three
percent reduction in federal spending
and where where do you start reducing
federal spending before I start off by
talking about the biggies Medicaid
Medicare not cutting social security so
security is simply a system that needs
to take in more money than what it pays
out without raising taxes you could
raise the retirement age you could have
a me
means testing which is very
all-encompassing and you could change
the inflate the escalator built into
Social Security from the wage index to
the inflation rate so why is it moving
on to military to then input military on
the table forty-three percent reduction
in military spending but doesn't that
leave us open to you know another 911 I
would argue that no it's not going to
leave us open to another 911 I would
argue that we're just not going to be
building roads schools bridges highways
and hospitals in other countries when we
would have those same needs in this
country you have recently have come out
against various kinds of social
conservative positions that other
Republican candidates are signing for
for instance michele bachmann signed a
kind of initiative you know that was
widely perceived and i think rightly is
anti-homosexual I Republican candidates
the other Republican candidates get it
that you know the days of social
conservative ism yeah as a government
issue seem to be behind us no apparently
not and and maybe maybe this is the test
maybe this is the election cycle that
this is really put to the test I don't
think it's if it is the issue I think
Republicans are going to be relegated to
a third party status after this cycle
that they'll never come back from okay
well thank you governor gary johnson
candidate for the republican nomination
for president in 2012 for reason TV i'm
nick gillespie